[Music]
in the early 2000s early aughts do you
say what do you say arts in the odds
early odds i was on my way to anot in
odd don't say that
and uh
and i couldn't find my little audition
sheet and this security guy the gate was
like
yeah freaks and geeks it's uh just past
stage four and i said no no it's not
freaks and geeks i'm looking for the
thing and he's waiting and i can't find
him like it's uh i'm trying to remember
it some movie and he does
freaks and geeks right
he like insisted that it was freaks the
geeks and i couldn't find my sheets so
finally i was just like uh
yeah freaks and keys he's like yeah
thoughts okay it's this way do you think
for sure that he thought that you were
auditioning for a freak or a game um i'm
guessing a geek
i'm sure yeah but the freaks were cool
yeah but the freaks on that show were
kind of geeky too weren't they uh james
franco oh he was yeah
um was
yeah i guess i could have been a freak
all right that's great thanks yeah all
right
the classes have fall okay glasses have
free
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your mostly geeky a little freaky host
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is uh
you're freaky would you say you about me
yeah
geeky or geeky but i mean i used to
would you rather be called a geek or a
freak that's the question
i'd rather be called a freak i think you
would
yeah i mean it depends on what kind of
freak exactly yeah well there's there's
uh trying to think of when i think about
the spectrum of freakness
is much
bigger than
geekness
geekdom i think that word when i think
of freak i think of like i mean you know
that that michael manson or todd
browning's freaks you know the famous
cult movie oh yeah 1920s yeah about
people with de deformities which oh it's
not cool no it's probably been cancelled
i probably shouldn't talk about it
anyway um
well why are we talking about freaks and
geeks
i never auditioned for it i was always
like and i love that show that's odd
yeah why was it before um
you were old enough well it only lasted
famously only lasted for a year
and so i don't know i don't know why i
didn't and having seen it now there
weren't
that well now there were parts i don't
know why i'm you know i'm gonna go on a
limb here and and guess why you um
didn't
i think you'd audition i have a guess i
do too i think judd maybe thought i was
too
i can't believe i'm saying this but i
think judd maybe judd thought maybe i
was too attractive to be a geek that's
exactly what i was gonna say yeah i mean
i don't know and not um interesting
enough yeah
because the guys who played the geeks
that's insulting no i know what you mean
it's like freaky enough to be a freak
yeah
yeah
i think judd has always thought of me as
being
like a like when i've done little parts
in his movies they've always been
kind of better looking people i would
say
yeah i think i think why are we talking
about judd apatow well i'll tell you why
quite simply
judd is our guest we're very lucky to
have judd apatow as our guest today that
is exciting it's cool he's uh uh like uh
the godfather one of the godfathers he's
i would say he's on the mount rushmore
of comedy not godfather is it mafia-wise
comedy all time or comedy now of the
last 20 years 30 years oh my god yeah
when you say that i would i would go
farther than that and say
he's
the
guy he's the most important person in
comedy in the last 20 years isn't that
incredible yeah i mean there are other
people who
you can make the case for like you know
ben stiller larry david uh-huh but i
would say judd aptow um
only because he
in terms of his
vastness in his career you know
and he's he's had his hand in so many
things even things you don't necessarily
you don't immediately associate with
judd he's probably had something
everything every every like everything
good movie every funny show ever he's
involved yeah and he's got a new movie
coming out this it's out now called king
of staten island the king of staten
island with pete davidson and our buddy
former guest bill burr is so good in it
uh so was merced tomay
and a an actress named belle powley
british actress i couldn't believe she
was british when i saw this movie she's
playing this girl from staten island
belle powley yeah
what do you what does that make you
think of belle bell's paul i know
strange right
probably have to cut this yeah
yeah she's incredible she's this i i
look drugs i've never seen her and i
thought who is this you know when you
when you find a performance that just
really jumps out and
and to to come well once you see it
you'll be i think i do want to see it
it's out uh it's out kind of everywhere
on all the platforms all you know all
the platforms how do people watch things
now everywhere
is it just on amazon
amazon everything
all the things you can find it yeah it's
not in theaters because our parents
can't find it nothing's in theaters now
yeah but it's in everyone's home now
nobody's in theaters the king of staten
island yeah i wonder if theaters have
become overrun now with uh mice and
vermin i bet some of them have yeah you
don't think they're sending people into
clean still i don't know i bet they are
um
anyway
yeah
but judd is i kind of seen so many of
judd's movies in the theaters i've been
in a lot of judd's movies but in little
parts you know like um i had a little
tiny part in funny people and i
judd would always do a thing on his
movies where he would have like he'd
call it a dvd day where he'd have a
bunch of actors come and do
little bits for knowing he was just
gonna use them on the dvd for like
outtakes or fun things uh which i think
is really i always loved participating
in um
and then we were you know we watched the
other night we watched uh walk hard
i had forgotten that he co-wrote it
co-wrote it it is so good
yeah and i was lucky enough to have a
little part in that movie's so funny god
it really is yeah it's hard to find a
movie in the last 20 years that he
wasn't
part of i felt like a really funny movie
i thought him tile day at night 40 year
old virgin
anchorman it's like you name him and
then you go back to the 90s with like
heavyweights and of course the cable guy
which we talked about cable guy is one
of our favorite movies so we get into
that we get into a lot of things uh
and it was just great i hadn't seen him
in years but it was great to catch up
with him and just to see him he looked
he looked you know he looked so young i
i wish people could see he had but he
had this
this real white almost totally white
facial hair and and hair hair well don't
spoil anything i don't know
i want to listen to it um anyway here it
is uh with the the legendary the the guy
the guy in comedy the most important man
in comedy yes judd apatow
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
look at your thick lustrous beard i have
like a uh
you know like a presidential beard from
the late 1800s
it's very garfield
yes i had to decide you know right when
this began the pandemic if i was going
to fall apart
or
if i was going to try to get healthy and
what i decided was to get healthy while
looking like i'm full oh that's good so
you surprise people i surprised this
i've lost about 12 pounds but you can't
tell because the beard is so big my face
is still filling you out yeah
oh it's good though it's um i heard you
recently talking about the choice of
whether or not to dye your own hair your
hair and how men at a certain age
is going to sound sexist but it it's
more shocking to me when men choose to
do it it's more obvious for some reason
well here's the thing it rarely looks
right yes and so when i see friends i'm
always like looking at their hair i know
a lot of actors and like that's that's
that's the bad way that's like it goes
this weird tint but i love that they're
allowed to because it you know you'll
see tom hanks sometimes yeah great hair
yeah he has a great hair yeah and then
you see him three months later
it's like tom hanks from 1983 yes he
looks fantastic and
and
he has permission to do that like if you
see
flea from the chili peppers every time
he can look different but when you're
just like schmuck like me if i go diet
not as an actor
it's like what the [ __ ] is judd doing
well why does judd think anyone cares
how he looked so then it amplifies your
vanity
yeah then i think you know what should i
do now my family they're all just like
can you please dye your hair because we
feel like you live we live with an old
man we don't want to live with an old
man we don't want to live with santa
claus
you know i'm only 52.
you could say i went prematurely gray i
don't know what the year is yeah that
you would say it's premature but what
would it be would very close
well what year
50 maybe i don't know you're but what's
interesting chad now that i'm i'm
looking at you i haven't seen you in so
long but your face looks relatively the
same as i recall you look young your
face and but your hair is now white
white gray like a light gray it makes
you look younger you know my wife has a
friend and she always like you know
forces her husband to dye his hair
and so my wife is always like why don't
you do it and
and i just think i'll look crazy yeah
but the thing i was talking about which
was making me laugh which is true which
is i bumped into john lovitz at a new
year's party
and he looked fantastic and i said oh
john you look great and and and he says
like uh it's my new shampoo
it's uh it's controlled gx you
you wash your hand it makes a little
darker you want it darker you just wash
it again when you like it you stop using
it
and
so
i got it i did it way too much and
looked like paul manafort
that's what happened
but then i did it another time and it
kind of looked pretty good it just made
my hair a little bit darker
but
what it would do is like near the top of
my head
it wouldn't get a little dark it would
go black so i
almost had like a spot
and i thought i just i don't want to
worry how my dye job is looking you know
i know
three women there's a lot of talk of
dying in the eyebrows yes it's constant
millions
and it's all about like did
the dye job come out good or bad you
know yes leslie will do a movie and they
want to change her hero's redder on this
one and blonder and this one and it's uh
it's just a
it's really important but it's stressful
because it's it's your head yeah i'd
rather just say you know what
i'll be happier if my head just looks
terrible but well i accept a bad looking
head or another way of looking at it is
it just looks natural which to me looks
so much better and and
and that way you look and you look a lot
less vain i mean you see somebody
like the people we're thinking about now
and don't want to name and they just
look to me the first thing i see is oh
they're they're vain they care way too
much and i'm talking about people who
are in there well into their 70s and 80s
yes i just got back from florida and
it's like who do you think you're
fooling
you are because your face doesn't match
your hair crazy
and black hair and you're barely able to
move
and on some level i'm bummed about it
like i i'm like because i
i i really went gray over the last
four years or five years where i went
fully yeah
and i was laughing with pete davidson
the other day
i i was sending him these videos of me
on the cbs sunday morning show
and so i sent him the one from me uh and
it's
2009. and then i did another one nine
years later
and i am a completely different person
yeah in those nine years i in the first
one i look 27 yeah
i think i'm like 43 or something but i
look towards fantastic and i'm gentle
and soft and kind
and and i'm talking about how i can't
really do stand up
that well because i'm not really that
angry and then you cut nine years later
and the piece is about me returning to
stand up and i'm furious yeah i look
terrible and old but i have so much to
say
and i'm really funny yeah like i'm
really funny but i'm like enraged and
weird
and me and pete were laughing at just
how the whole thing fell apart yeah it's
funny it fell apart but it but it's
funny that it led to good comedy it led
to content for you again
me getting more neurotic and in the rage
i couldn't find 23 when i wanted to be a
comedian right that's interesting do you
think you need a certain amount of anger
a certain amount of rage to be a
successful comedian
well certainly you need a lot of passion
i used to think it was anger and i think
for most people there is an anger or a
sense of injustice like the world is
[ __ ] yeah let's try to figure out
what's wrong with it here's the [ __ ] i
have to deal with yeah that's a great
majority of comedy is
can you believe this right what is going
on but then there are people who are
just so creative and
and they don't have any of that you know
uh
and they're still funny i mean
but i guess underneath it
people are trying to i think if people
trying to figure something out that's
bothering them or they're trying to
learn about themselves with great energy
yes and it's not all anger you mentioned
pete davidson uh i just finished the
movie i loved it so much judd i love uh
thank you it's it's really beautiful and
um bill burr i've never seen bill really
connect the way he does in this movie um
how much of it was is the way you make
movies improvised um
and how much of it and where did it come
from uh this where did the story itself
come from well
in terms of bill that's the comedian
that pete really always looked up to
and they were you know
friendly yeah you know they were they
were friends but clearly
you know you know bill talked about how
like you know he lives in la
and uh he lives in new york but to pete
that's the guy
and i think bill was always very kind to
pete yeah over the years and i thought
that relationship will
will be uh visible on screen like that
affection for each other totally and i
and i try to cast that way sometimes
where you want to tap into real
intimacies
and i thought well a lot of the movies
are hating each other and because in
real life they love each other yeah
even when it's dark it'll be really
funny you'll just you'll feel the
connection yeah like you'll feel the
inevitability of their connection yes
even when they're cursing each other out
that is in the movie it is very clear
and sometimes it's more clear when
they're cursing each other out that
there's real
passion like you said uh yeah
he's destined to be pete's new dad yeah
yeah yeah yeah because of how angry they
are at each other that they're similar
in certain certain ways so did pete so i
mean he was somebody he looked up to and
i noticed that he
had co-wrote the script
yeah you so was was that important to
pete as well to because a lot of it is
there's a version of his his own life
that's at work
yeah i mean we go through the list like
you know who do we think would be right
for this and very early yeah you know he
he was the big proponent of of working
with bill
yeah and
when we started talking about the idea
you know how it began was that he wanted
to do a movie about
being concerned that his mom had spent
too much time
worried about him and had neglected her
life yeah because she was worried about
how he was doing in the aftermath of
him losing his dad yeah sure his dad was
a you know a firefighter who died on 9
11 and
and that made for
you know a difficult childhood i think
that's just a burden that it's hard for
other people to even understand what
that would feel like when you're seven
and judd not that you lost your parents
at that age but they did go through a
divorce were you able to relate to that
in any way i think on some level what i
related to was that comedy was a savior
in some ways
it was a way of trying to figure out the
world
and he
started doing stand-up at 15 i started
doing stand up at 17 and we we did it
very aggressively as a very young people
you threw yourself into it yeah it was
just our lifeline and our obsession and
i think you know the idea of like taking
trauma and then trying to be hyper
vigilant and figure out how how you're
going to succeed in the world yeah so in
the movie it's a it's a bit of an
imagining of what would have happened to
pete if he didn't find comedy and he's
just stoned living with his mom after
his sister goes to college and then she
starts dating for the first time another
fireman and now he has to confront
everything
in his life by hanging out with this guy
who he really doesn't want to hang out
with the performance that he gives is
really beautiful and present and
connected and and very truthful um
there's one thing i'm thinking of in
particular where uh it's it's steve
buscemi is talking about there's a group
of guys talking about his dad
and it felt so organic and that stuff's
so hard to do i'm not telling you i'm
telling people listening just just
sitting around
shooting the [ __ ] and laughing it's a
hard thing to capture because you're
trying to script it
and you know there's certain things you
need to say but you also know that in
order to show the camaraderie of
firefighters i need them to genuinely
make each other laugh right i don't even
think i can fake it i don't think i
could write the perfect joke uh huh and
then have steve buscemi fake laugh but
it's so well acted yeah i actually need
bill burr
to like surprise him how do you blend
those two i guess that's
that's the challenge tricky i mean i
mean a lot of it is that you rehearse a
lot
you do the best you can you rewrite the
script based on the rehearsal
and then on the day you start shooting
the script and you slowly say to
everybody it's you can drift go ahead
yeah you can expand you know the points
you have to hit yeah and then when you
have someone that's hysterical like bill
and it's so funny like bashemi yeah that
they're gonna if you if you have enough
time because a lot of times when you're
making
movies your day is rushed but if you
know
we cannot be rushed today this is going
to take
all day yeah yeah
then the actors relax because they don't
feel like i'm going to get two takes in
it they're gonna get ten things right
they might get the whole afternoon and
then you just go i i hope magic happens
but like something like bill burr you
know he hits the joke like in every
scene you go i need him to surprise
everyone at that table and he would do
it every single time and in character
too not like a guy trying to be funny
yeah exactly right in character
he did it too so the moments you're
thinking of they're completely
rift
knowing like all right we're gonna make
some jokes in this area they're telling
stories about partying pete is also
great in it it's one of the scenes he
has very little dialogue but he's just
it's uh he's listening and it's it's a
great he's just absorbing all this stuff
it feels so rich and
it's really such great work and
speaking of great work your daughter uh
i also felt so old because i was like
who is this actress is great
oh it's your daughter i think everyone's
kind of seen
grow up as an actress and um she is so
good i mean
really incredible but i i wondered about
mod how do you cast mod and not iris in
something or is it uh does that cause
friction well it plays pete's sister
yeah and it was about age yeah and mott
had gone to college and it was it was
about how you know pete's character is
like smoking pot and flailing about he
doesn't know what he wants to do with
his life and he wants to be a tattoo
artist but he can't really practice and
he's not doing it seriously and that mud
is super hyper vigilant
about getting amazing grades and getting
out of there yeah yeah she wants to get
out of there and she's a
hyper achiever uh-huh and you know mod
had that experience before you know in
her life huh um like i always would say
to my don't go to college it's not
[ __ ] like we were the opposite of
the people who cheated to get into
college you're like just don't go
me and your mom went for 18 months i
don't even know if we should have gone
at all
and then she was somebody to get her not
accepted somewhere
and she would go like on the weekends
and
i'd my ninth hour of studying for the
sats oh my gosh
she so she had some of that that's funny
that's an act of rebellion for her
yeah
and iris we had worked together on the
tv show love and she was so funny
playing arya the uh spoiled child yes
yes she's great great in that yeah and
we had done that for years i hadn't
actually worked with mod i haven't
directed mod since
2011 had been nine years uh uh eight
years at the time
and so it was really fun to work with
her after she had worked on euphoria
and had really learned how to act and
those scenes are funny because she's the
one character who's allowed to really
tell pete off
as a sister say this is the nightmare
you're creating for us
she seemed also so connected to pete did
they know each other before some of
those scenes when she's going off to
college they're heartbreaking i mean
she's she she feels so
raw and and what truth was she mining in
that in those scenes well i think that
you know she is a very grounded
actress you know she's just very real
she takes after leslie in that way yeah
she
has known pete a little bit but for a
long time
but i think the issues there she
understood she understood sibling
rivalry she understood wanting
everything to be okay because you know
her first big scene is it's the night
before college
and she's about to leave and she wants
to say to pete just go easy on mom yeah
just
give her a break yeah just give her a
break but also she wants to get out of
there and she probably knows it's not
gonna work right but it's almost to
assuage her guilt yes she needs to like
say the things she needs to say and then
run for her life well i tried
yeah i did my part
yeah yeah that's so true
uh you mentioned improv and allowing
actors to um go off and
when did you start employing that method
judd how early on in your career
when did you latch on to that idea that
some of the most truthful stuff is just
going to come
through improv and through the the
brains the actors i always knew that
barry levinson did it on diner
from the earliest age i knew
paul reiser went with a friend to the
casting call for diner he was not
supposed to read
and he was waiting in the waiting room
and they said do you want to read also
and then he got the part not his friend
god
with like steve middleman or mark schiff
you know
kind of
comedians and
and then i would hear that he just would
riff on the set and a lot of that was in
the movie all the stuff you can eat that
sandwich yeah yeah
who's better sinatra mathis uh-huh and
for some reason as a little kid that
stuck with me like wait you can make up
stuff yeah
on the
the writers must hate that but they love
it i just thought that's so incredible
because i think it was because it was
one of my favorite movies of all time
still it is
and the first stuff i ever did where
there were scripts was i wrote on three
tom arnold's specials they were called
the naked truth it would be like tom
arnold is going to solve
the environment there's tom arnold is
going to solve this problem it's like
kind of reality based comedy sequences
yeah and they were little two-minute
sketches we did one with frank zappa
we did one with uh martin mull
sandra bernard did one
all these amazing people that roseanne
knew would would do these specials with
us where were they airing judd where
would something like that on hbo uh uh
oh we did one with chris farley where
chris farley who had been doing jackie
thomas show
with tom
it was a sequence where he was going to
teach chris how to meet women and he has
like an earpiece at the mall
it was chris walking up to strangers
like
on them
and i just remember that chris did this
thing that was so funny he sees like two
pretty girls and it's all real
there's no actors involved and he's
walking with a yogurt and when he gets
like eight feet in front of them he just
trips on purpose and lands like where
his like chest lands on top of like this
full yogurt then jumps up it's like hey
how's it going
you're pretty you're pretty
but we would riff you know we just
thought i don't know is there anything
else funny we just thought i guess you'd
get a bunch of stuff yeah and then when
i worked with stiller band would riff
like crazy oh i bet yeah and i just any
sketch we did ben would just keep going
i didn't even know what improv was i
just knew ben keeps going
[Laughter]
i don't know he's talking a lot
yeah like no one explained like second
city in the herald right no just ben has
a lot of things he wants to try
and then when we did uh
the cable guy
ben was a director
i watched him guide
jim through that oh interesting what was
it like watching ben
direct jim carrey i i
god i would love to have been a fly on
the wall for that it was also it was
like a an incredible moment because it
was you know jim did ace venture yeah
yeah and then he did the mask right and
then he did or maybe he did ace mature
dumb and dumber the mask he had one
after another two right so he has
they're all the biggest movies ever yeah
they're all
amazing and then he wanted to do
something different he definitely wanted
to say to the world i i want to show
some other
moves other attitudes i want to do
something darker so he was excited to do
a really strange
movie which was kind of making fun of
movies like hand that rocks the cradle
yes
you know there was another movie we
loved it was called unlawful ray leota
and it was the kurt russell ray leota
and yes you know it's you know the new
guy in town that you think is your
friend and then slowly you realize he's
trying to destroy you there you know
there's a lot of those kind of movies
then and the the cinematographer of
unlawful entry
was that was was a no it was robert
ellsworth oh who oh
met for cable guy oh wow we didn't hire
him and then he did you know boogie
nights and and uh and he did king of
staten island
yes yeah oh my god you know ben
you know i didn't know how to do any of
this so i i was watching ben work with
jim at the time i was writing at the
larry sanders show right they brought
you in to do rewrites on it that's what
i had read i was doing revisions and i
was the producer of the movie
and
you know so it's just peak gym
gym on fire so funny ben so passionate
about it and we laugh so hard every day
laughter and then the movie we put it
together and put the score on it and it
was just way scarier than we realized
on the set like everything we're just
cracking up oh my god and then we see it
and the crowd is like you know we're
getting huge laughs but they're also
kind of terrified like they really think
jim is going to murder matthew well that
character inevitably has to kind of turn
dark i think i think that jim was doing
something that we almost didn't quite
understand when we shot it which is he
was so committed yeah and so vulnerable
yes as an actor that there was real
sadness there yes there was real
neediness
and that's why i think 24 years movie
came out
people still watch it and it holds up
and
because it's not just light like there's
real emotion there's real emotion it's
about i mean god that whole speech at
the end about it's about the internet
about it's about what's going to happen
to
the world uh with the explosion of the
internet and
it's about yeah culture it literally
predicts everything yes i mean he's like
one day we will combine our television
phone and computer
and you'll be able to uh play video
games with a friend in vietnam yes yes
yes yeah
it's just so good and i've always been
so curious about it um you can see
matthew broderick laughing in a lot of
those
a lot of those takes when it's jim's
coverage you know i remember matthew
broderick you know you have these long
scenes where jim would be just riding
his face and going
stephen and he would just like have
these long rants
that were so troubling yeah you know
about you know sending him hookers and
stuff like that yeah one day matthew
just said to me he's like i can't think
of a new way to react to this
[Laughter]
matthew broderick's so good too i mean
that's not easy to do um
yeah that scene specifically it's one of
the greatest scenes uh i think in ev in
any comedy when they're having eggs it's
i think it's once you know don't let
your eights get cold um
get out of my house it's so it's just
the best um he's saying that he tried
the hooker out to make sure she was good
for him
and then assured him that she's clean
not a drip life
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when you're a young
writer comedian yourself you're
producing a movie like that
what do you want to do what are your
aspirations around that time
was it to direct movies to direct more i
think right when that project came up i
very quietly went like uh i would direct
it if you want me to
and everyone was like no
and i was scared to direct i really
had an irrational terror of the idea of
directing
and then one day chandling said to me
you're directing the next episode oh wow
of the larry sanders show it was the one
you had written
no it was just you know it was a really
beautiful gesture
he didn't ask anyone else who wrote for
the show to direct the show wow an
enormous amount of people would have
been great at it and deserved to do it
yeah it just wasn't something he asked
people to do
and a lot of those people became amazing
yeah yeah who were writers on the show
um but and then i was just thrown into
it wow very next week i directed this
episode which was called
putting the gay back in
litigation it was about mark it was
about um
uh hank's assistant
uh
suing the show for sexual harassment
because everyone makes gay jokes all the
time oh wow wow
and uh
and so it was like a heavy episode it
was really funny yeah wow and it has a
scene
you know
there's all these scenes of
hank
videotaping people saying goodbye to
larry because larry's stepping down from
the show so it would be like drew
barrymore saying goodbye and then ed
begley saying goodbye and the great
one was a bruno kirby ah i love
and the joke was that jeffrey dammer who
who was just so hysterical yeah was was
saying uh
you do it faster
you do it faster it's just brutal going
like
congratulations larry uh
like uh
we love
you and have a great uh life after the
show and he's like uh i'm not feeling it
i'm not feeling it
it's just him giving bruno kirby too
many notes yeah yeah
and then bruno kirby says uh
you know i don't have to take notes from
you i was in the godfather and
hank goes i don't think so i don't think
so which one
he goes the second one
because i only saw the third one
i've been thinking about bruno kirby
lately because uh i've been thinking
about fred willard a lot since yes yeah
and um and fred so i've been re-watching
some of his you know waiting for guffman
and we saw mighty wind recently
and it occurred to me that fred did
something
that is one of i think the most
challenging things to do which is he
played an unfunny person he he's like
masterful at playing aggressively
unfunny people yeah you know people who
think they're funny yeah and bruno kirby
did that better than anyone in in good
morning vietnam um
well i so remember the day on anchorman
when you were playing fred's
nerdwell son yeah screaming at fred
and you know people don't realize that
when we did anchorman we tested it and
we threw out
the a story yeah
you know the whole story of anchorman
wasn't in the shoot isn't that correct
there was a very complicated story about
which was kind of making fun of like sla
and patty hurst and yeah they're like
eco-terrorists or something
yeah there was a whole terrorism somehow
yeah but you know and
so then we cut it all out and cut out so
much schwarzenegger
incredible yeah and yeah yeah amy
poehler was in it yeah
and my rudolph and chuck d was in the
movie and kevin corrigan and and then
mckay
the director and writer adam mckay is so
funny he took all of that and he made
another movie with him yeah he literally
took the entire a story re-cut it and we
had enough footage to make a completely
different movie which we put out on dvd
yeah and there's a lot of your stuff
with fred yes in it it's good
we're so funny oh that was such a dream
come true for me to get to do those
those days with him but that was that
i've seen that wake up ron burgundy
there's also some of the funniest stuff
with
the anc the team the channel four news
team
uh there's i think it's steve carroll's
audition
scene is it
he's eating garbage and he thinks it's
part of the buffet line from the food
bank and there's an argument to be made
that the audition
yeah that steve's audition for brick
is the funniest thing of all of it yeah
this is just the auditions yeah and in
in the audition
will as ron burgundy keeps telling him
like
you should what are you eating what are
you eating he's like eating uh i'm
eating i think
i would break just what it is i think he
goes like everyone calls it like a cough
a coffee filter with a little cigarette
or uh no no he calls it a burrito with
chocolate chips on top yeah he goes
that's not a burrito that's a coffee
filter
and um with garbage in it yeah and then
the joke is that
karel in the improv just chooses to just
keep eating it no matter how many times
ron burgundy is telling him like that's
garbage and it's the joy
from steve and everyone laughing in the
audition yeah but there was also a scene
in it that they cut out
which is in wake up around burgundy
which was
that they're all in the woods the anchor
team
and immediately
they're they're lost and then minutes
later they're debating who to eat oh
yeah yeah
it becomes like uh alive yeah and and
then mccain does this very subtle thing
where the camera moves a little bit and
not that far in the distance you see
like the mcdonald's arches yes yes
as they try to figure out who's the
weakest person to eat
yeah they've been missing for like 20
minutes maybe do you remember any of the
jokes that you did with fred i remember
one where i said uh
i'm 12 i'm a man now
and i lifted up my shirt for some reason
i think to show him my non-existent
chest hair
and he said yeah i'm sorry i don't have
my magnifying glass uh
something like that and i what i
remember about him is that people would
be laughing in between takes and
i remember him always kind of like
talking to himself do you remember that
like he kind of be off
there was no part of him that felt like
he was soaking anything up or or
relishing
focus yeah focused yeah yeah no he was
the funniest we had him on undeclared
playing a teacher who makes history come
alive and he acts out the entire
kennedy administration in 90 seconds oh
my god
including the assassination and
it's so
weird and and funny and then
we worked with him on the bench show but
you would bump into him he was the
nicest man of all time yeah you know
there are certain people in the business
you meet and you think oh that's the way
we're supposed to be right right right
right who and who was that you who set
those examples to you early on
i remember
i went to visit david milch
who created ted wood and co-created nypd
blue yeah and he had a lot of interns
working for him
and i said
you know how do you afford you
afford that you know implying you must
not pay them very well
how does that work right how do you get
away with that
he said judd you know
i actually pay them ridiculously well i
make a point of really overpaying them
and i'll tell you why i do it because
people come to hollywood and usually
they get treated like [ __ ] when they get
here people really abuse them and then
for the rest of their life they're kind
of bitter and they think
they're allowed to now abuse everyone
below them so by treating them so well
the second they get here i feel like i
might change the entire way they treat
everyone the rest of their their lives
yeah yeah and the cumulative effect i
thought
who even thinks like that like how do
you even have that notion
i mean such a beautiful appropriate way
to think yeah and
of course i never did it but
but it was quite a lesson had i followed
it yeah it's true and it probably would
have a profound if enough people because
there aren't that many people at the
levers
you know if enough of them behave that
way
it would probably radically alter
the entire industry and also his
encouragement of me
i mean i always talk about channeling
but david milch in some key moments was
encouraging so after i did uh funny
people
you know which you know i i love the
movie but it certainly was a dark movie
yeah
and
i was trying to decide how i
felt about it
and he he just was very positive and
really praised me and he said you know
like you moved me
you know many times during this movie
you really touched me
and i know what you're trying to do and
keep going in the keep going in that
direction
don't retreat like this you're on the
path go in that direction and that's why
i did this is 40. i mean he just hearing
him say that yeah yeah that kind of
validation yeah and realizing that oh
that's my job with other people i got an
email from you to this day is one of the
nicest things anyone said about me and
it was after you had seen i think herbie
herbie fully loaded yeah yeah yeah the
last is great well yeah but i was happy
to do it and have that job but the last
thing i thought
was that it would it would lead to an
email like that from somebody like you
and it was again i mean that that
you do know i was going to say you have
no idea how encouraging that is and how
far that goes but you do it seems like
which is probably well
you know
we all work so hard
and
it's so meaningful when people pay
attention to what you do they notice
strong work
uh and anytime anyone succeeds
you know i i
i always try to reach out to people and
just go like man that i mean like i
remember seeing that movie and going
like yeah that movie is like so funny
you know like there are certain movies
that you see and you just go like i know
it's like silly and it's herbie but man
they executed all sorts of stuff like
way better than you would expect yeah
but there's genuinely really strong
things in it i remember freaky friday
was like that yeah yeah yeah was that
mark waters i think uh yeah and it was
just like wow they really completely
pulled that off that was a really
strong fun movie and i don't think
people realize how hard that is how hard
it can be yeah yeah in any kind of movie
is so hard to make work every genre you
know we always respect the movies that
are like depressing and heavy or like oh
yeah they're they're really going for it
with their hearts but but but even like
just comedy and lighter
get that touch that touch right now
miracle if anything works well of course
and chad that's why i
love
your movie i mean like you do that
better than anyone i i
what is what is the what is the next
challenge for you you've made a lot of
documentaries now that are
really profound i would say the avett
brothers one and the gary shandling one
um
what do you want to do next what is the
next challenge
i i usually don't think about it in that
way
i just wait for something that feels
worthy of being obsessed
right right i hadn't directed a movie in
five years i you know i had one or two
things fall apart but it it took me a
while to find subject matter that i felt
like
was
uh worthy of investigating obsessed
over and and that dug into some areas
that i felt like i hadn't
done yet because i did want to make a
movie about sacrifice a lot of the movie
is about
firemen and nurses and the risks people
are willing to take to help other people
and right well i wanted the movie to
come out now and not wait a year for it
to be in theaters because i thought this
relates to what we're all going through
we're all traumatized we're all grieving
that's what pete's character story is
about is how
he deals with the loss of his dad and
you know it's a comedy but it is about
how we process traumatic events in our
lives and and so i thought yeah i wanted
to get out there
and it is a tribute to first responders
so i i've tried to be a little less
obsessed
with box office and all that because
even the movies that no one went to see
in a theater
ten years later people will call me and
just go i just will still walk hard for
the third time yeah oh yeah
and you realize oh everyone catches
up with it
i'm happy it's it's going to be
available well cable guy is a good
example of that i mean cable guy wasn't
considered a hit at the time and it's
one of the most
you know beloved
comedies now i think um
so so
these a lot of the work that you're
doing a lot of the comedies you you make
are you you have a producer role on it
uh is it like well like walk hard um is
it challenging
judd to give the reins over to somebody
else to give leeway to
filmmakers especially when you maybe
disagree creatively
how do you yeah i mean most of the time
it works out i i just think that those
people are way better at what they're
doing than i am so we're doing walk hard
which is jake kazan's idea and i wrote
it with jake jake's just such an amazing
director yeah and you know it was
written for him to direct but also the
entire time he was making it i thought
i'm not capable of doing all the things
he's doing
right now i mean he has a real mastery
of cinema that i i'm many steps behind
i'm trying to catch up but i'm not quite
there yet and i felt that way when we
did super bad i never threw my my hat in
the ring on super bad because i thought
this needs almost like a scorsese-like
energy to not just be a bad high school
movie it needs it needs a higher level
of cinema
to work and greg mottola seemed like he
would do such a better job
than me and he did i mean he did
everything i dreamed that he would do
and his his work with seth and evan on
the revisions was really remarkable and
human
and so that's part of my job is to know
when i will ruin things and what about
now where do you think comedy
is headed i know this is a pretty
open-ended question are you concerned
that
social media culture for example um
is making comedy too
obvious will comedic nuance get lost
with the shorter attention spans
are you ever afraid of that you know i
have multiple minds on it you know
sometimes there's great comedy
that comes out that i never see or i
find no interest in and i think i'm
getting old because i'm not attracted to
this thing that people love right
and then i'll force myself to watch and
go like i kind of get it but i don't
know
or is that fine and it's not about me
getting older it's just
whatever that's not the kind of thing
that i
like so you know i will have those
moments right yeah is it over yeah or
you're listening and then other times i
think no i like a certain type of
emotional comedy for the most part i
mean i love writing
super silly walk hard
type of stuff yeah but i i i'm still
trying to make a movie in the model of
the movies that meant a lot to me like
diner in terms of endearment you know
that's what you're doing
i'm trying to do
and i think that they're not a lot of
comedies being made for the movie
theaters but that's mainly because other
types of movies might make a billion
dollars right right and comedies might
make a couple hundred million dollars or
a big one but the studios are investing
in the possibility of a movie that makes
a billion dollars and then they can make
seven more right as a result they're
just making less comedies because it's
not their highest priority right
universal loves comedy so they let let
us make our movies and they've been
amazing partners but i think the
industry as a whole they want things to
work in china and russia
right and i don't think they're
investing in it the way streaming is
investing in comedy where you have these
incredible shows like romney and
you know masters of none and fleabag and
they're giving those same writers who
maybe would have made movies 10 years
ago series right you said i saw a tweet
of yours recently where you said you're
consuming all the things you said
there's something like i've watched
everything that people tell you to watch
yeah i've i've gone through everything
yeah there's nothing left
but what what have people recommended
what is your next thing you know what
keeps happening i keep getting into
fights with my wife where we'll be
watching a show
and we're having a blast enjoying it as
a couple and then i'll just come home
from something and she's like i finished
it without you
so i have so many shows
where you know like we're having so much
fun watching the crown season three and
she's like i watched eight when you went
to the store i couldn't help myself
i'm very excited about
um
i guess well maybe excited isn't the
right word because i don't know yet but
everyone keeps saying that
zero zero zero show i'm supposed to
watch oh okay i'm supposed to watch
fouda i haven't watched founded yet i
haven't watched um
i'm only on episode three of normal
people oh my gosh these are all kind of
you know it's like high school people
and there's a lot of sexual stuff and at
some point you know we looked at each
other and went i feel kind of weird
right now feeling a little weird
so we like we took a break i mean we're
gonna jump back in but it's like i know
these are people who are older than 18
performing this but it's still uh we're
watching the high school banging right
now and i don't know and graphic you
mentioned the show euphoria i saw an
episode of euphoria and i felt like i
was 80 years old
i was like and my daughter is in it uh
yes
luckily she plays the good girl
thank god
[Music]
[Music]
these are just really quick lightning
round okay let's do it okay uh what is
your most commonly used emoji the clown
emoji oh really uh
you know like i'll throw to the kids for
no reason like knife pill
uh emoji
i don't use the pink one i don't like
the poop one i like to try to
find a way to make it look like violence
and madness
like a four or five combo just something
going terribly around
uh that's funny um where is everybody
now by the way are they are they at home
are they at your house yeah
we've got a pack quarantined house it's
a roller coaster of emotions every day
god someone one of us is melting down
every day it's like it's like a carousel
of
you know three of us are happy one is
crying every day and it just it twirls
uh do you ever watch the old stuff now
thinking about liz leslie so good and
cable guy uh do you ever go back and
revisit some of those movies you know i
i don't
i can't say that we do
yeah i'm not sure why and i i'm not you
know i'm not the kind of person that
would do it leslie would do it more than
me
yeah you know if something's on you know
we might watch a little of it but we
don't go like let's rewatch it we
haven't watched this in in 10 years
and we probably should and i love
watching her because she's
so funny and so good yeah and and that's
not a that's a tough role in cable guy
there's it's a kind of a high wire act
because she's got a
that she's she can't be too freaked out
by jim carrey in fact she's got to be
kind of like
charmed by jim carrey and and his
yeah that's exactly and this is also one
of these great gifts is she she could
pull that off like she can do georgia
the jungle yeah in love with george and
and you you really
fully believe it she's already making
magic real like in 18 again
was it 17 again yeah
well i get him confused because my
friend charlie schlotter was in 18 again
17 again i really enjoyed blockers
because you know leslie carried so much
of like the emotion of you know what it
is like to be freaked about your kid
leaving and yeah you know she finds a
way to make things so grounded and real
and then riotously funny and that's so
hard to do sure yeah even in um 40 year
old virgin when you know that famous
scene where she throws up in the car
she's still grounded
in that scene i think that's what makes
that scene so
funny she's real she's grounded and and
fine she's playing the truth which is
yeah and i think that's the key to all
of this stuff is yeah you know i always
say that everyone i'm working with
the world people are really broad
like when you meet people in real life
they're nuts like people are crazy you
don't have to be false in a movie to
have really funny broad character
totally because in life people are so
weird if you could be in a professional
athlete judd what what sport would you
want to play in your fantasy tennis
that's the only sport i ever try hard at
okay um frustrated but i choke i'm a
choker yeah me too yeah i could be up
sick i could be on a 5-0 and i will lose
seven every single time if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be
just ice cream just yeah i love ice
cream even now
i've i i've been walking a lot so i get
up in the morning and i walk for about
two hours or two and a half hours every
morning really fast
and then like at 10 at night i'm like i
walked a lot today so i think it's okay
to eat the ice cream
yeah i always
i always wondered if that's stuff that
paul does and this is 40 the cupcake
stuff i wonder if the cupcake stuff was
you oh yeah i mean what was funny is we
were shooting all the cupcake stuff
where he's sneaking cupcakes
and so we have a lot of cupcakes on set
and
i'm at the monitor unless he's walking
to the monitor and i have a cupcake in
front of me and literally as she's
walking like a magician i just kind of
like moved my notebook to hide the
cupcake like under my chair and paul
lapel who was helping us punch up the
movie when leslie walked away she
laughed so hard she's like
i can't believe that move there the
misdirect and the yeah okay
yeah you were like houdini um
that's funny
if you uh should be ice cream any
particular flavor of ice cream and any
go-to i have to say the you know i i
will lean
any version of a vanilla fudge
you know the haagen-dazs people with the
mint ship
minship chocolate or vanilla so you know
i just get the vanilla and then i have
my
you know the foxes like you bed or
whatever chocolate syrup and i just keep
pouring it in an enormous amount and
then i eat it off the top and then pour
an enormous amount
it's the unhealthiest thing in the world
and i don't know if i'm ever happier
than
like hiding from everybody eating ice
cream
it's not good it's not good i gotta get
a handle on it
um if well now's the time to do it in
quarantine uh what's what's this is one
that you're gonna hate me for what is
your favorite movie of all time
i think that the movie
that i always think about is being there
yeah
it's just a perfect movie and it's so
funny and it's about so many important
things there's some comedy set pieces in
it that are just unrivaled yeah and it's
so
uh smart about politics i mean you know
donald trump really
is a variation of chauncey gardner
totally yes a darker version of it but
the end of that movie is
all these leaders of industry looking at
chauncey gardner and they start having a
discussion about making him the
president
right oh my god because they know they
can control him so just as as the years
pass by
it just becomes
more and more
yeah prophetic and and it really used
television yeah in a great way because
chauncey gardner knew everything he knew
from tv and there were tvs on in almost
every scene and he's copying what people
are saying on tv to people and they
don't notice that he's
an idiot repeating things from tv that's
right and now we have a president
who his schedule says executive time and
all he does is watch tv yeah yeah and
one channel really it seems yeah if you
had to live somewhere else chad where
would it be i would
probably live in new york in in the city
i'm from long island that's right i i
would like to spend more time there uh
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
who would you pick three people dead or
alive i guess one would have to be
groucho oh yeah you love the marx
brothers
buddha
right you gotta go buddha sure you gotta
go groucho
buddha
and
eleanor roosevelt
just feel like she knows a lot of stuff
she'd be good at a dinner party she'd
tell you the dirt i bet she'd be a good
time charlie
uh what's your favorite marx brothers
movie chad out of curiosity i always
think about knight at the opera just
because oh yeah there's something about
it that makes me laugh because i love
that the marx brothers
hated rich people yes
yeah like if anyone was wearing a tuxedo
in a box brothers movie you knew they
were going to kick this [ __ ] out of them
or something off the lapel yeah
they just hated the you know the power
structure and i feel like as a little
kid
that duck soup was like
they hated government but yes it was
like
it was a funny attack and just rich
[ __ ] right and that's what was so
great about
margaret dumont was that she was the
perfect i i i've heard that she wasn't
really even announced she didn't know
why they were funny apparently yeah if
you don't get the joke and you get to
feel it and they and they're just
tormenting her yes yeah i loved all
those movies yeah me too oh man uh who
who is your do you have a favorite
muppet is there a muppet that you think
i kind of relate to
i used to watch a lot of
sesame street as a kid yeah and then i
always
wanted my kids to watch a lot of it just
because i was so happy to have an excuse
oh yeah to watch it again i probably was
into burt and ernie
yes
yeah you know there's just something
about the friendship of it as a little
kid
i mean you could say that everything
i've ever done is an attempt to do a
version of burnt ernie
that's funny well there is it's about
yeah friendship and also the there's a
laurel and hardy element i think too
yeah
sweet guy
you're more than another guy yes yes
every comedy needs an irritated person
yeah super bad as burt and ernie yeah
yeah that's true uh
my favorite ones too including yeah
cable guy or what about bob um
if if you could have one superpower what
would it be i guess it would be
i guess it would be to fly yeah i have a
lot of flying dreams yeah oh yeah yeah
you fly to specific places or just the
idea of being free
yeah yeah and sometimes i wake up from a
good flying dream and if you happen to
wake up where you remember it you're so
happy yeah like a good one good flight
there's a good flight there
i kind of know what it feels like now
yeah uh
if you could be one age physically for
the rest of your life what would you
pick what's so funny is
when you get older you have pictures in
your house and you you tend to hang
pictures and fill all the walls and then
you just get older and you never replace
them and then you don't want to replace
them because if you keep replacing them
then you actually see your aging process
decline yeah
and and that's depressing so then it
turns out that whatever age you hung the
frames is where you think you are
because i don't really look at myself in
the mirror that much but i see pictures
around the house and that was 12 years
ago so
basically i guess it would be 12 years
ago yeah i'd like 12 years ago like 40.
uh if you could be um
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny oh yeah i would rather be
called unattractive i call myself
unattractive i've made a point in this
pandemic to not groom
and just
like let it go and and i love it you
know you know my family when they have
to work and they have to get dressed up
and you know they
they're trying to look good and then i
could grab the same suit every time
every event
i literally could be
from in the shower to in the car in like
eight minutes
yeah
i heard you say that your fashion
choices are the same as they were in
school you know in eighth grade oh i
know i i'll see a 14 year old boy once a
while and go like that's my outfit
that's what happened because i can't
think of what the new
style would be yeah what would you have
no idea what is my fashion like my euro
trash guy my like thin suit guy and my
tom wolf guy and i just i just give up
at some point and just go i don't know i
guess i'm just
you know in a polo shirt and cargo
shorts and i know it's lame but it's
comfortable yeah i see people my own age
who change their look
and i think i but i also tease them i
think well we're you're cultivating this
thing this is not uh this is brand new
this is as you saw
and i'm so bad about it because like i
have friends who you know
they get some success and then they're
into fashion all of a sudden and they
they love it they love looking great and
there's nothing wrong with that and i
just always just laugh like you're
really doing a whole number now yeah
yeah
it seems absurd to me uh and to spend
money on it anyway um
which which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia would you say i have to say that
it's betty white because she
lives near me i've never seen her no but
people always point to this house and
they go betty white lives there
and i want to like knock on the door and
just go
i'm here if you need me
yeah don't you ever have the courage
never had the courage oh wow
uh i feel like you've earned that right
to
cold call betty white
um have you ever done that with anyone
else somebody you admire you just look
them up and
you know what i heard that phyllis
diller lived near me
and i hunted down her phone number and
they're like this is the number of her
secretary i always remember that they
said secretary uh that's her very old
fast secretary
and
and then i i just got
nervous to call and then she died yeah
and i never i never made it to phillips
i think she was like 99 or so probably
as a result of not having heard from you
i i don't know if that would have kind
of got her excited a little bit kept the
blood pumping but all right i thought i
felt bad about it i think i felt like ah
man i wish i went over there but it
still hasn't moved me and yeah to do
many white
yeah
i get very shy
um uh beetles are the rolling stones do
you prefer
oh that's a good question i've never i'm
not a big fan of having to choose in
that way
yeah because it's so
different and you know me and stiller
many many years ago wrote a movie for
the rolling stones
so they wanted to make a movie that
would be like
a story
that would then cut to them performing
and so oh my ben and i and this is in
the
early mid 90s wrote a movie
about bret ben and a very young brad
pitt being like almost like deadheads to
the stones and following them on tour
and then thinking they see a stalker who
we wanted it to be andy dick and then so
they're following the tour they keep
seeing any dick and then they they're
trying to like get to andy dick because
they they're nervous because he seems to
be stalking them and then at the end you
realize that andy dick is claiming to be
mick jagger's illegitimate
that was the basic premise
but then in different moments you would
cut to rolling the rolling stones at
concerts and and in their hotel room
performing and we wrote this script and
we had to pitch it
to the rolling stones oh my god
so if you can imagine me and ben like in
toronto in a room with the whole band
oh my god what was that like well i told
ben to pitch it and i said i'll just
jump in with the jokes but you pitch the
story i'll jump in with with like
the jokes
and then i got so scared of the band
that i did not speak
as soon as we walked out ben was like
what was that you said
nothing oh my god well yeah i can't
imagine them they're all sitting there
they're they're at your you have their
attention to have their attention oh
yeah you don't want keith richards
looking at you for a half hour straight
oh my but ben was amazing i mean ben
had just courage
he didn't throw him at all he was
fantastic
and i remember he said you know i want
to shoot a kind of like shaky like
handheld you know rough you know kind of
like give me shelter and keith richards
goes
all right but this time let's do it
without the murder
[Laughter]
did he me
trying to be funny or yeah
that's really funny but a dark sense of
i was like this scared me yeah but that
joke scared me
and then afterwards you know we leave
the room
and we're outside the door and ben has
his ear up against the door he wants to
listen to their debate about whether or
not to make the movie and i'm like ben
if they catch you keith richards we'll
kill you you can't like eavesdrop here
and then uh
we went downstairs it was at a like a
high school in toronto and
we go downstairs and they say you know
you want to watch them rehearse they're
rehearsing for a tour
and then ron wood comes down and just
gives us the thumbs up
and then they come down and they'll just
watch them rehearse for like two three
hours and they performed
only for us there's no one there it's
just me and ben
eight feet from the band
watching them uh
shut it before
do you remember when we we had that
experience on
oh [ __ ] with fleetwood mac do you
remember this yes that was incredible
too that was incredible what what was
that movie it was for
well they were doing
um they were on the sony lot
just practicing for a tour
yeah and i think we all just
found some way to be allowed to watch
them like run a show
and that's what it felt like it felt
like a private concert that they were
just yeah
there's like eight people there that
people pulled in a couple of like chairs
and couches and then they just did it at
full force
yeah
that was that was a great one um i've
had i've so enjoyed getting to work with
you over the years and i i so
value the the your creativity and what
you've done i i just uh really happy i
got to do this with you so oh great i'm
glad i love the show i'm glad i got to
be a part of it oh
i'm also glad that i took a caffeine
pill and i i feel like i was on my game
i'm not going to lie to you
like i gave you everything i had i could
talk to you for so long and you've just
done too much that i'm curious about but
um hopefully we get to do it again
[Music]
so that happened
stephen
yes it is it is to me oh that's my it's
sorry i wish i had friends like that get
out of my house god i love that movie uh
did we talk too much about that movie do
people people know that uh
i don't know i mean not for me i like
the movie
that's also where he met his wife and
you didn't he didn't mention that
yeah he didn't surprisingly you talked
about his wife uh-huh quite a bit at the
end that is where he met leslie manning
but you talked about the cable guy and
his wife a lot but you didn't talk about
how he met his wife but he was my guy
that is weird i thought it was weird he
had ample opportunity to be like yeah
that was a good experience i met my wife
there yeah yes was he at that thing that
we did um you wrote this thing for me
when we like roasted
holy [ __ ] well i didn't write we talked
about that in the show i don't know it
wasn't supposed to be a roast when i
hosted this comedy it was an award show
like right it was the american comedy
wars or something i forget what it was
for
all of these like illustrious
comedy people it was like participating
it was like the biggest stand-ups
were doing a chat it was a charity it
was a charity thing so yeah it was one
after another like disease and
uh gary shandling and and just like
sarah silverman everybody everybody and
christian wrote a lot of these things
for me their friend kier yes kyra had a
lot of funny jokes and it was um we
liked it we thought it was funny so
justin was the host of it and his job
was basically just to introduce the next
stand-up for their set we had an idea
that we'd have this running thing
throughout as a bit that you would think
that you justin would think that this is
the dress rehearsal of the nba
performance
at one point you came out with just your
boxer shorts on and you're
and you would like say something to the
lighting guy
so it was this like kind of marginally
funny
i thought it was
sort of funny and i was backstage
watching it and gary shambling
kind of moseyed up to me and he goes
he's not going to do that throughout the
whole show is he
and i
i know he's going to never know
i don't know i hope not oh my god oh my
god
that's right you totally i totally threw
you under the bus
i would have done the same thing
and then remember we did that bit with
aziz and sorry where i was like
anyway and i we did this long setup for
aziz and the stuff he had done and i was
like
anyway
ladies and gentlemen aziz i'm sorry uh
and we kept stopping by saying i'm sorry
instead of i'm sorry i'm sorry um can we
adjust the light back there i feel like
it's a little hot on my face and i could
see aziz out of the corner of my eye
like he kept he kept doing false steps
out
you know not knowing the bit again the
marginally funny bit at the time i
thought it was really funny but
it feels less funny now it does yeah
in the moment 10 years ago it felt funny
yeah i don't know how he has time to do
all this i i don't either when he said
he walks two hours every morning that's
crazy and he watches everything that's
[ __ ] i know how does he have time
i don't walk at all and i don't i i only
watch him practical jokers and i feel
like i don't have time for anything you
don't have a wife and kids
oh i know i know
how are my days going by so quickly yes
it's so impressive and he seems like
oh
he you know he's got just the right
amount of like
neurosis and angst about it well i like
how he puts zero effort into his
appearance
i know i really i really
respected how little he values looks i
heard him talk about that on another
podcast and i was like i thought you'd
like to hear that yeah i do too i
i think maybe i care about it just a
hair more than he does but not much
right not much i aspire to care about it
as well
yes me too me too
uh and his i i think he was maybe
alluding to jonah when he said he's like
you know i have good friends who
who
have like started really caring about
their you know style and their clothing
choices oh i didn't think about that oh
i wonder if he was talking about joan
because jonah has become like a gq like
a style like a fashion guy
which is crazy yeah uh what jonah always
had an eye for that kind of thing like
we didn't have right but it's not yeah i
know i never saw that no i know
i know i wonder i didn't think about
that i was thinking maybe talking about
pete because pete also had is like a he
talked about watching normal people you
haven't seen normal people no no and
he's and i agree with him it's very
uncomfortable to watch with all the sex
the sex scenes are so graphic
and i know like the two
you've been watching with maggie yeah
we're like four episodes in but the two
main actors
are over 18. but they're playing in the
beginning they're playing high school
students and it's like
the most
really graphic [ __ ] like
crazy sex scenes p and v
uh that's a that's a judge that's from a
job movie right yeah isn't that jonah
see a lot of those great headlines are
but judd also like created a whole genre
of comedy i know which is i mean that's
why another reason why i think he's like
the guy because how many people can you
say that about that's true
not only did he has he made a lot of hit
movies a lot of people have made hit
movies but he like developed a whole new
style of comedy i know i like slacker
stoner yeah that's that's him isn't it i
think so like
bro i don't know it's like yeah still it
was funny you talked about um burton
ernie and how
how
uh his movies are basically like an
extension of those two characters it's
true they're
and they're romance movies superbad
works on
uh it's sort of knocked up obviously and
40 year old virgin they're really like
romantic
and it's funny that he analyzed at the
end he analyzed his own performance
and
for a guy who is as accomplished as he
is it wasn't it's still it i i detect in
a charming way
a hint of insecurity genuine insecurity
genuine insecurity which i
well it's hard to believe someone who
has done that many things could still
happen i know but it just goes to show
you that it's not really about that it's
not about accomplishments and stuff and
and i think it also is speaks to
i think it also helps him in his films
as a filmmaker you know he's able to
connect uh
it's there's something accessible about
his the insecurity that his characters
display also he he clearly doesn't see
his career
in any sort of um
way where he's thinking like what next
for judd apt i know you kind of asked
him that question he said i i know you
know i just think of like i'd wait until
i find the thing that i want to obsess
over next i like that i like that a lot
because it shows that
how much he cares about the things he
does but it also shows that he doesn't
have some grand plan where he's trying
to
you know reinvent himself in this way
it's just whatever sticks to him well
that's having watched his documentary
about gary shandling that seems like
something that maybe came from or or was
at least
inspired in part by gary shandling and
his zen
ethos you know right
and which is so fun it's such a great
examination of that that that
documentary and such a good if you
haven't seen it at the avett brothers i
haven't seen that oh my god i love their
music oh my god you would you'll first
of all you'll love them a lot more don't
know if that's possible well all right
try it out i want to see it is it how do
i see it uh it's on one of those things
i don't know
uh let's full circle let's read a letter
okay this is from pete subject is
greetings fellow nutmeggers
oh connecticut yeah
for the oh yeah i should have explained
that i knew what it meant but as the
host of the show i should probably
communicate i love that spice
he knows how much we love nutmeg i do
love nutmeg
yeah i like not i haven't you don't have
it very i like it
i haven't had it i don't have it all
right do you want an egg dog on eggnog
what else do you have nutmeg on eggnog
yeah how often you have eggnog
oh my god it's so hot in this room by
the way this isn't the letter yet okay
subject is greetings fellow nutmeggers
which is a reference to connecticut to
the nutmeg state
oh it's hot in here
not like sexual no
hi justin and christian my name is pete
and i too am originally from the great
state of connecticut
meriden to be exact wow yeah do you know
some from uh it wasn't bob bernier from
meredith
weird
yeah i remember but also something we
should communicate to people is your
latin teacher
yeah hell of a head of hair bob bernier
still does he does you saw him recently
yeah facebook oh yeah i gotta get
facebook i don't want facebook i i i
wasted enough time i am a wicked huge uh
wicked huge fan of you guys and love the
podcast meredith is a little farther
north so it's got an actual closer to
boston yeah yeah they say the word
wicked up there yeah people might not
know that but in in parts of connecticut
there's uh there's a slight accent at a
certain point in the state
the people get boston red sox and boston
you know that's right patriots the
boston sports team it goes from new york
met and the mets over to the red sox but
we're from the southern part of the
state so we get mets yankees the
tri-state
tri-state yes i'm a wicked huge fan of
you guys and love the podcast i'm
currently working at the post office as
a letter carrier up in washington state
and listened and listened to it at least
two times a day
that's cool pete thank you i'll download
previous shows and just laugh as i
deliver mail that's cool to think of a
male man
listening to the show you know it was
cool yeah
uh i've always thought uh it would be
fun to be a male character me i was just
you know everything would be fun to be
milk
there's something you know why you get
to be outside you get to know them yeah
friendly everyone seems friendly with a
man very task oriented but you don't
like dogs and then maybe that's true you
know why i don't dislike dogs but i
don't like people i shouldn't
who cares i don't know curiosity oh
that's nosy
uh you know what i i think it might be
from uh how much we love mr rogers
neighborhood growing up and there was
that that i loved that character the
mailman
what do you say cliff slavin too
yeah cliff yeah
i think i'm more cliff clavin than chad
apatow when it comes to um work ethic
uh i'll download okay this is back to
pete i'll download previous shows and
just laugh as i deliver mail max jerry
oh kb and many more of course grandma
jody too ah it's funny that this mailman
in washington state knows grandma
i joined the navy back in 19 oh cool i
joined the navy back in 1994 and retired
here in washington back in 2017.
the wife and i love it here and just
stayed in the pacific northwest with our
two kids i love i want to get married
and be married for a long time and be
able to say the wife and i yeah and that
sounds like focusing yeah i wanted to
thank you both for keeping for keeping
me laughing during these difficult and
trying times thanks pete uh with all the
social injustice issues protests and not
to mention the song going pandemic yeah
it's like oh my god i remember i
remember that
i really need this podcast ah every
single one i've listened to has made me
laugh literally out loud usually in the
post interview ah
so i hope he's laughing so not me not
now
i haven't said anything funny
he'd be a maniac if he was laughing out
loud right now so keep it up and cockets
and bullets ah speaking of jonah
thanks again pete dao ps can you guys
give a quick shout out to my daughter
kayla unfortunately we can't her senior
year of high school was was pretty much
ruined oh sorry pete sorry kayla kayla
dao um sorry kayla but she stayed as
positive as possible and she's attending
central washington university in the
fall cool good shout out kayla yeah
congrats and uh and that must suck the
senior year to be i mean we've talked
about it i know i wasn't in love with my
senior year but you gotta look on the
bright side caleb didn't have to go to
class as much it's pretty cool i know
but kayla sounds like somebody who
probably wanted it i know uh i had to
miss prom yeah anyway that's cool that
pete and and she's got a daughter a
daughter i'm like losing it it's so hot
in here you know look at look how much
i'm sweating are you
you're a beast of stress
uh yeah cool that kayla's dad thought of
her to mention her um and that uh anyway
would you rather oh he's got a would you
rather great thanks pete okay
i'm gonna read it in what i think is
pete's voice would you rather have your
fats have a very strong fruity scent
gross
or
[Laughter]
have your burps sound like a fart wow
wait
okay
would you rather have your farts have a
very fruity scent
okay i think it means bad fruity because
there's good fruity until i'm aware like
fart fruit i'm aware of the difference
between good fruity and bad fruity sorry
i was telling the audience i'm sure
they're aware too okay don't mansplain
fart smells to me um or have your burps
sound like a fart
burps sound like so you'd be like
[Music]
uh burps sound like a fart um i would
rather
those are my favorite kind of parts the
ones that kind of like go up into
nothingness they just go up into a
register that that only like animals can
hear you know i gotta say
i wouldn't really mind either option if
i would think about a very strong fruity
scent not a good fruity say i'm guessing
pete means a bad fruit i don't know why
you're guessing that
why would you why would that be bad if
you're also
even bad fruity like bad fruity fart
smell it's not the end i'm thinking like
an air freshener in a car you know well
if it's that offensive that it's like
affecting everyone around you then i
would rather have my birth burp sound
like farts
yeah also there's not
that much difference in the sound of a
burp and a fart also you could probably
the way you can with any burp you can
muffle it you can muffle up your mouth
just put your hand over your mouth if
you're going to fart burp
unless it's just like a very farty fart
sound you know there's certain fart
sounds that are more like
like air and then there's certain fart
sounds that are like
yeah so oh don't don't i know it well i
i don't mean to mansplain fart too but
yeah but imagine you're in public and
you burp in like
during an important business meeting or
something and it sounds just like a fart
to the point where people just like a
rattler exactly yeah
then i think
it would be tough to deal with that
i would pick because then people would
think you farted and that's embarrassing
exactly but i would still pick that
though i would do because of very strong
fruity sound that way you there's no way
you cover that up
i've always wondered why they didn't
invent a pair of underwear
that
oh hey speaking of fart burps or burp
farts sorry
sorry pete um
i always wondered why they didn't invent
a pair of underwear that uh that kept
your fart smelling or turned your farts
into a nice smelling scent or no no
scent
i don't know some sort of filtration
system in the in the lining of your
underwear
imagine how much that that invention
would be worth i bet they've tried i
can't believe i'm saying this but that's
not a bad idea
okay well this is as good as a patent
anyway thanks pete and and and thanks
and kayla i don't know what i'm thinking
kayla but uh congrats congrats that's
right good luck in college in the fall
yeah central washington university i
wonder what they call that senwashu
thanks for writing if you guys want to
write in our email address is justin
life is short at wondery.com stay in
your accent now life life is short at
wandery.com
uh life is short at wondering we enjoy
hearing from you and we didn't do a
quarantine episode last week um
in the
in the wake of all these protests and
unrest and um we also didn't do it this
week as you've noticed and
part of the reason for that is
because we've been in
we've been out of quarantine and they
are quarantined episodes and we've been
up in massachusetts
working on some other projects and we
just came back to connecticut now to
record this but uh we don't have
recording equipment in massachusetts so
so uh we have not been doing these
quarantine episodes but we
uh
are
kind of unsure of the future of them at
the moment but what we would like to
enjoy doing them and what we would like
to do is take all the parts we enjoy and
transfer them over to the regular
episodes and do an occasional uh
check-in episode yes um but we yeah just
are not able to make it a regular thing
right now we also really want to thank
everybody who responded to the james
blake episode i've gotten some such just
great feedback about that and some of
the conversations it has sparked and i
can't thank james enough for being so
open and honest and uh
and having that that time devoting that
time to uh this very vital conversation
so thanks to everyone who checked that
out if you haven't uh please take a
listen um
and uh thanks to everyone listening
thanks so much to
the great the legend the king he's the
legend uh he doesn't act like it which
is no it only makes you wear his cargo
shorts yeah his cargo shorts and
t-shirts he's the best and check out uh
the king of staten island great
performances such a such a really
beautiful movie uh phil peep pert pete
davidson bill burr uh belle powley
uh the great marissa tommy such just
everyone a steve buscemi is amazing in
it i'm glad judd apto doesn't dye his
hair i know it'd be such a let down i'm
gonna go on on record right now
publicly and say i will never dye my
hair
i will do you don't both have to go on
record publicly and say you won't dye
your hair i won't either unless it's for
a part
if it's for a part uh really you don't
think you will no
no i think it looks ridiculous i mean i
hate i'm sorry for everyone who dies
with every man out there who dies there
is that sexist day is it sexist because
on women i've got you it's that seems
weird when men do it i think it is
technically sexist yeah but i that's how
i feel yes i think it's weird when men
die their hair i know i can't help it i
just lived too long during a time where
it was
it was it wasn't done also for someone
like you more you than me i would say
you have such a boyish face despite your
man
still look at that
you are a candidate for
hair dye i know but here's because when
if and when you do get gray you're i
have a couple your face will probably
not match your hair
it'll be strange it'll be like oh why
does that young guy have great well
it'll be a little like remember when
matthew broderick started going gray and
was like whoa
yeah he has this boyish face i respected
it me too me too i have i have too much
i this is why i don't think i'll die my
hair
i have too much respect for
the men who don't and it's a good reason
i uh this is his sexism
it doesn't bother me when women dye
their hair and it probably should
equally to a man but it doesn't i mean
well sorry uh chew on that everyone yeah
that controversial statement uh and we
will see you in a couple days uh and
thanks uh can't thank him enough judd
and thanks to judd for all the years of
uh
the fun work yeah all the joy yeah that
guy's provided so much laughter also to
me and selfishly to me allowing me to do
some of those movies yeah we uh we i
feel like it's fair to say that everyone
listening really owes that guy one and
and check out walk hard uh it's a
shameless plug because i'm in it but uh
we forgot what a great movie it is
really funny oh and this is a real
shameless plug speaking of bill burr uh
new season of f is for family is uh
dropped on netflix so um season five
season four
of the great billboard show any more
self-promotion nope that's it all right
see you soon thank you
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short it's hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hoded oh boy
it's coded by hoda
and my hoda what if hoda took over for
me oh that'd be amazing and you took
over for fajorda
um
hoda what a great name she you know i've
made jokes with hoda on her show anyway
about
shortening her name because kathy
whatever it's a fun joke okay uh is
hosted co-hosted co-hosted by my hoda
chris christian long senior producers
michelle
miesh
also produced by megan mon monaco megan
monaco and the audio engineer is sergio
enriquez
executive pro's are
marshall louie and hernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
like think about all the great
comedians like stand-ups and like great
comedy movies you always understood the
joke
think about it
you know
yeah it's clear i mean this at least is
clear yeah but think about watching a
laurel and hardy movie or a
or a
abbot and costello movie or a
chaplain movie
you always understood
sure it was very very clear yeah whether
you found it funny or not right
right you understood of course what they
were doing
of course
isn't that crazy then and now all of a
sudden after like
we've it's comedy's devolved into just
like
saying sentences that vaguely sound like
jokes and leaving it open i know yeah
like you figure it out
you